what up GQ you got your highness five
out of tens here we're a lion Rudy you
know us is food beast oh my god the
steak just melts GQ sent us across the
country to find the best cocktails food
and bars around
you're watching where's the bar
all right we're in la Tinseltown home of
the Lakers and we're in an interesting
neighborhood we're near fairfax we're
not anywhere that's like super crazy
there's a lot of hip little shops street
where stuff going on when we talked to a
BART center named Ryan he told us the
place that we had to go to had a fat pig
painting on the side of the wall and he
was like skull terrine best cocktails
the chef throws down in the kitchen so
we're here to put that to the test
hey ma'am let's see what's up let's see
what's the real deal welcome to terrine
terrine is basically a French brasserie
we're doing classic drinks classic
French food with a modern twist we're
surrounded by Hollywood Beverly Hills
mid-city the Groves over there I heard a
little bit of old Hollywood here like
that's that's what you're getting your
your purist with the with the spirits
the classics are where it's at man this
is the city of elegance or elegant
drinks for me it's all about a respect
for about this neighborhood yeah this
town and and for the spirits there's
sort of a phrase that's going around
right now that's really popular which is
oh man that drink was so good I couldn't
even taste the alcohol if someone said
that to me about one of my drinks I'm
gonna make for you guys today a drink
I'm calling the stylist it's a 50/50
martini that's what the stylist is it's
got that name because it's made with
Bombay Sapphire and safir and it French
is what they call the needle on a
turntable keep the bar nerdy stuff up
really high because I think it's awesome
that's sarcasm
the martini that I was talking about was
pre-prohibition Prohibition hit and all
of a sudden you're drinking whatever
somebody's cooked up and I think that
truly was the beginning of the end for
the drink
prior to Prohibition people were trying
to accent the spirits they were tasting
those spirits they were trying to figure
out how to make it taste even better but
the second you started this idea of the
spirit
that that's when everything fell apart
but it's taken a while for us to realize
like we don't need to drink this way we
can we can taste these spirits we can
mix it martini is a cocktail a cocktail
in order to be called they've done like
we yeah a cocktail is spirit sweetener
bitter and water so anytime you remove
or add any ingredients you no longer
have a cocktail for the traditional
vodka martini that people get it's just
spirits and water so that ends up being
what's called a thoroughbred you and I
enjoy thoroughbreds all the time
in the form of shots it sounds so much
better than taking a shot can I get a
thoroughbred of you know so 50/50
martini is an ounce and a half of spirit
an ounce and a half of vermouth and then
your bitters that makes it a 50/50 that
makes it the 50/50 what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start with gin Bombay
Sapphire is an insanely delicious gin
it's perfect for what we're gonna be
doing when I think of LA I think of the
martini
you know old Hollywood it's about
creating elegance every drink has really
got to be a focus on that
so this is the stylist and this is
tutoring to Sarina to the Los Angeles
and see you guys there it is that's
amazing I can taste the alcohol you
could taste the off off the loose come
in later yeah start just the dry comes
in first then you start to get the the
different traditional vermouths and the
cuñado and then the sherry finishes it
up that's you know that's your honest
what do you guys have by way of pairing
this with something that I can eat we've
got Kris Morningstar in the kitchen he's
doing awesome classic French food I
think he's got something working for you
guys that is gonna be just as classic
but elegant as this drink a toast to the
chef oh yeah hey how you doing I want to
introduce you to a couple of my friends
all right and they wanted to see what
you were cooking up back here you know
what do people love about terrine like
when people come here to eat are there a
lot of things that people are just crazy
about is it just as I know they're gonna
get sort of like a interesting twist on
old stuffed I think the whole thing is
it's really straightforward food done
really really well
you know a tornado Rossini it's old
borderline outdated but when you eat it
all together and you got spinach and
beef and foie and truffle it you
understand why it's a classic and why
it's not outdated so I think what we're
doing is we're just kind of bringing
some of these old things back to life
making them fresh again and of course
from credible drinks so I've got a
petite filet cooked it really gently so
it's perfectly cooked and then all we're
gonna do it do to this is take it and
get a sear on it that's the flaw yeah
yeah so yeah smells like duck liver fat
so I'm just gonna go like soft this
guy's already been seasoned so we're
gonna let that beat and then I got some
spinach here the way we're gonna do this
is my favorite we're gonna cream it out
but we're not gonna use any cream so we
want to dry the spinach really out so it
can absorb as much of the sauce now I'm
gonna give this steak a little bit of a
paste and then the last thing is just to
finish our spinach just a little bit of
truffle butter
Oh a little bit of regular butter oh yes
oh yeah yeah I like that screams maybe
Arab that's amazing Ollie all right so
I'm gonna make a little truffle salad
here little dressing touch of salt wah
grah lay it right on top do we got the
creaminess of the spinach we got the
crunchiness that raw truffle has some
crunch to and then because it's classic
we're just gonna fill that rim with
sauce so here we go Oh tournedos Rossini
oh oh it's amazing them yeah oh my god
the steak just melts that's the best
ratio of spinach to butter I've ever
seen in my life I feel cheers to that
chef that's amazing thank you very much
thanks a lot my pleasure so much thank
you Rudy he liked you guys here's our
awesome get classic gonna come to read
and eat dude hey terrine was the spot to
go to in LA chef Morningstar hook it up
with that steak it was nuts Ryan
actually taught us a few things behind
the bar that 5050 martini was nuts next
time you're in LA come check out terrine
like Eli said super awesome bring your
girl bring your mom grab a drink grab a
bomb steak
call it a night can't do much better
than that oh wait around the world ooh
the real world huh and then we walk the
same way absolutely